das ist ein wirklich revolutionäre
ansatz einem forschungsteam aus schweden
ist es gelungen wärme ohne
zwischenschritt direkt in elektrizität
umzuwandeln
und zwar mit einer effizienz die mit der
effizienz von modernen gasturbinen
vergleichbar ist die entwickelte
maschine basiert auf sogenannten
quantenpunkten und kommt komplett ohne
mechanische bauteile aus ein thermo
elektrisches nano kraftwerk also wie das
genau funktioniert welche schwachstellen
es hat und welche praktischen anwendung
davon profitieren könnten das jetzt bei
klick zum science fiction hier gibt's
täglich faszinierendes 1 videos
abonniert den kanal nur dann verpasst
ihr nichts herzlich willkommen bei der
stromerzeugung durch diese generatoren
oder gasturbinen sind mechanische
bewegung unabdingbar durch die
verbrennung der treibstoffe entsteht
hitze und wird dann über mechanische
bewegungen in strom umgewandelt und
selbst bei atomkraftwerken funktioniert
die energieerzeugung noch nach dem
steinzeitlichen prinzip wasser wird mit
der erzeugten hitze zum kochen gebracht
und treibt so eine dampfturbine an die
jetzt neu entwickelte wärmekraft
maschine im nanomaßstab dagegen braucht
keine mechanischen bauteile sondern
basiert auf sogenannten quantenpunkten
konkret ist die werbe kraftmaschine
folgendermaßen aufgebaut als wärme
reserven nutzt das forschungsteam 2
drehte mit unterschiedlichen
temperaturen nanodrähte aus indium for
speed und indium arsenid wurden als
kleine strukturen dazwischen gebaut und
dienen so als quantenpunkt zwischen den
metallischen reserve elektroden also
eine art filter der nur elektronen mit
einer bestimmten energie passieren lässt
die einzelnen elektronen werden von dem
temperaturunterschied angetrieben und
wanderten über den quantenpunkt und zwar
von der wärme elektrode zur kälteren
elektronen dabei leisteten sie arbeit
und es entstand ein kleiner stromfluss
den das forschungsteam in form von einem
volt spannung messen konnte dem
forschungsteam zufolge sei das neue nano
kraftwerk hinsichtlich der effizienz
vergleichbar mit modernen gasturbinen
dazu einer der beteiligten forscher
einer linke unser ansatz zeigt dass ich
wärme
ein zwischenschritt direkt in
elektrizität mit hoher effizienz
umwandeln lässt bisher ist dies
allerdings nicht mehr als ein reines
grundlagen experiment das so nicht in
die praxis übertragen werden kann die
temperatur differenz zwischen den
elektroden reservoir an lag bei nur
einem grad und die absoluten
temperaturen nahe des absoluten
nullpunkt es also bei minus 273 15 grad
celsius praxisorientierte anwendung sind
in diesem quasi tiefgekühlten
temperaturbereich nicht vorstellbar
das forschungsteam ist dennoch
optimistisch denn auf dieser grundlage
könnten demnächst wartungsfreie nano
kraftwerke entwickelt werden die
aufgeheizten elektronen in computer
prozessoren oder aufgeheizten elektronen
in solarzellen nutzen könnten
auch in sensoren oder bekannten
schaltkreisen könnte der erzeugte strom
genutzt werden selbst wenn die ausbeute
eher klein ist der energieverbrauch von
serverfarmen könnte so zum beispiel
deutlich gesenkt und sie effektiv schon
in den prozessor selbst gekühlt werden
und zu was computer dann in der lage
sind erfahrt ihr hier
k s als teamplayer menschen chancenlos
auf dem kanal von raum zeit lockt der
zukunft dafür hier klicken auch eine
dringende empfehlung von mir hier geht
es zum kanal direkt schreibt mir in die
kommentare
wie euch der kanal gefällt ansonsten bis
dann bleibt dran